[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre cómo va kóvacs la
coalición de más de 170 países que busca
garantizar a los más pobres el acceso a
la vacuna contra el cubit 19 nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor gracias por
acompañarnos una vez más que logros ha
tenido kóvacs hasta el momento
realmente el logro más importante es
crear esa cadena de solidaridad en donde
todos los países financiados
autofinanciados los más four y los más
ricos tengan acceso equitativo a las
vacunas es una iniciativa que ya es un
hecho real que tiene un presupuesto que
ha adquirido unas vacunas y que está en
el desafío de la logística de la entrega
equitativa y solidaria para cada uno de
los países que son miembros de la
estrategia ahora doctor hasta el momento
como bucks ha firmado acuerdos con facer
bayón tec y oxford astrazéneca esto es
suficiente podrá firmar más acuerdos
para abastecer a toda la población y qué
significa aprobar su uso de emergencia
sin duda se necesitan todas las
estrategias y las plataformas que sean
aprobadas de lo que se trata es de
adquirir todas este tipo de grupo de
vacunas en un precio muy razonable que
estén disponibles en cada una de las
regiones del mundo y recuerde mos que
esta pena q de c's
su objetivo es cubrir el 20% de la
población priorizando las poblaciones de
trabajadores de salud y más vulnerables
pero no es al 100% de la población esta
es una estrategia de emergencia para la
fase aguda de la pandemia después de
sólo una estrategia para sostenible en
el tiempo el hecho de que entre estas
vacunas va a ser necesario frente en más
vacunas más plataformas
y así lograr que sean distribuidas para
todos de acuerdo a las circunstancias de
cada país y de cada región ahora doctor
es la pregunta del millón seguramente
difícil de responder pero vemos un poco
de esperanza la vida podría volver a la
normalidad cuando la gran mayoría de la
población mundial esté vacunada además
cuando podría hacer esto
probablemente la antigua realidad no sea
la que volvamos va a ser una nueva
realidad y lo que vamos a tener que
adaptarnos es muy probable que cuando
logremos la inmunidad de rebaño cerca de
12 años que haya ese gran cerco de la
vacunación retomamos las actividades que
consideramos normales sin embargo todo
este periodo de adaptabilidad lo que nos
debe hacer es enseñar a reflexionar y
mirar que podemos cambiar para que esto
no vuelva a suceder a suceder y sin duda
la solidaridad dejar el egoísmo y
trabajar en conjunto de ser el principio
para adaptarnos a lo que llamamos una
nueva realidad pero va a ser pronto rose
seguramente que sí a que así sea doctor
y le pregunto cómo evitar entonces que
los países más ricos que están en kóvacs
acumulen vacunas para ellos mismos
creo que la estrategia busca es eso que
hay países que hacen acuerdos
bilaterales para adquirir sus propias
vacunas pero ya sabemos que también
algunos países de éstos financian para
que otros puedan acceder la edad
la idea es aquí la equidad sin embargo
hemos visto que hay países que tratan de
acaparar más allá de sus habitantes
obviamente esperamos que eso no sea una
política sino algo reactivo porque
realmente aquí la vacunación no importa
si es para un individuo una región un
país nos tenemos que vacunar todos o si
no la estrategia vacunación no funciona
no puede ser un solo país acapara las
vacunas a una solo y los demás no nos
sirve de nada
así es doctores que para los países más
pobres kóvacs podría ser ésta la única
salida a la crisis es decir 9 le
pregunto cómo ve la región de américa
latina en ese sentido
la región de américa latina como muchas
regiones del mundo es desigual hay
países que tienen mayor poder
adquisitivo de los que no tienen casi
ningún poder adquisitivo la estrategia
de coachs lo que va a permitir es que
todos tengamos la accesibilidad a la
vacuna pero recordemos que esta es una
estrategia que solamente da la vacuna
pero no capacita el personal y la
logística depende del país el plan de
vacunación entonces podemos tener las
vacunas pero cada país tiene que tener
una estrategia un plan de vacunación
capacitado su personal y la estrategia
logística para hacerlo si no lo si no lo
tiene no importa si llega la vacuna no
la va a lograr aplicar entonces es una
extraña estrategia que también de manda
de los gobiernos locales la estrategia
para poder permitir ese engranaje para
que cuando ingrese la vacuna se pueda
aplicar entonces no es necesariamente
estar en cosas que asegure la vacunación
depende también del esfuerzo del país
para la logística así es doctora y me
quedo con la palabra que usted
solidaridad que tanto nos hace falta en
estos tiempos gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 a
usted está mi gracias hasta aquí el
final de cinco minutos
[Música]